Christian MRA first of all
congratulations but I have to ask you
what's wrong with you why are you
playing the
French yeah that's a question I ask
myself a lot yeah this game this game he
he he came up with some good preparation
of course I had no business winning this
game it was just it was a lucky blunder
take us from the he's one of my role
models again it was a very difficult
game right uh you were on the defensive
for the duration of the game you were
very passive and you just had to wait
and it's always very difficult to wait
right to make those waiting moves that
don't create any additional weaknesses
you managed to do so and then in the
critical moment he wasn't able to find
the right way tell us a bit about how
you approach those type of situations
where you have to make those difficult
decisions yeah this game was actually
like frankly it was quite depressing in
the middle of the game because the issue
is I think after this move I think like
Bish 4 on the opening after I made this
decision to go back with Knight E7 I
just never made another active move
again because the issue is if I don't if
I don't if I allow him to take on F5
then the issue is he can put the bishop
on H4 I believe and then bring the
Knight to say E3 and then it becomes
quite difficult to defend F5 tell me
again which move you uh uh 15 go to 15
move let's say knight uh Knight E7
Knight F
E7 got it by the way just to interrupt
you for a second this was a draw as we
anticipated let's get back to it uh move
15 after Bishop to
G4 yeah so this Knight at B7 it was very
it was because actually it's this whole
position it's kind of this whole kind of
this whole position engine I think it
overides it some engines they they give
like plus one here yeah it's not that
high but it's against correct play like
what he did against very slow play it
becomes quite unpleasant to play because
the issue is one the main plans that
black is kind of revolving on here is
that every time white goes say like G4
or F4 four you can you can meet it with
with say either G6 or F6 so basically
you wait for white to come and try to
try to beat you and then you try to make
a draw not so you're not trying to make
a draw you fight back with but what
happened in the game was that he uh he
he he brought the bishop to H4 Queen to
E3 and after this like every time like I
go g I can never go F6 because H6 is
always hanging right and I had I had to
go G6 in the game to stop F5 but like
now now okay this position is basically
two assult position white can waste like
15 moves and black can't do
anything and that's the type of
mentality you need to have as a French
player you know you need to be able to
suffer like this on your own accord it
seems like but then you're rewarded for
your
suffering stuff it the stop
it all right you play this move a B4 and
at this point finally things are getting
a little bit less tense at least it
seems like because you're simplifying
the the position on the queen side how
did you see your chances right
now I thought I was still trying to
fight to survive like I thought this
position was compared to before it might
be a bit better but the issue is even
though like visually it looks like I
have some more played now F7 is just
extremely weak and I had to make this
decision like a couple moves ago with
Rook B8 mhm I really wasn't sure about
this it's it was quite
uh I had basically two ways to try to
hold this position either I tried to
bring my pieces to the king side and
just hope that I can fight on this
minimal ground or I just try to just
push the pawns throw caution into the wi
Play Bishop B8 start playing B5 B4 and
just start trying to break on the queen
side and I decided that okay suffering
with Rook f8 Queen d8 is I I've had
enough suffering in this game but let's
do something let's do something a little
bit more active I look I agree with you
I feel your suffering uh but it was
rewarded no that was our analis what
happened I think were some crazy lines
like this was the moment Queen B1 I
wasn't sure like maybe I thought Queen
B2 was another interesting candid move
because with Queen B2 if I go bc3 you
take with the King you don't get you get
a much better version of the same you
like you don't have to give up D4
there's no more Knight B4 also but I
think maybe Queen B2 like B3 is some
kind of some kind of an idea I'm
not I'm still not sure what's going on
here like Bishop takes F7 like Rook A2
might be a candidate move Bishop takes
C8 King A6 like
uh but okay realistically like maybe
this this this might not work actually
because Queen B1 and just F7 f8
next but maybe like Rook takes C2 but
King but Rook takes E2 just King E3 but
King E3 KN takes E5 like I take have
some
tricks7 and but yeah don't I was
thinking I had some Perpetual here but
yeah still very complicated yeah maybe
it's maybe there's nothing
okay so he played King to Queen to
B1 I think like yeah practically like
with with black having one minute on the
clock Queen B1 was kind of a good thing
to see that okay at least now I can get
some pieces off the board mhm and it's
not like even this position after Bishop
7 like if I even if I don't have Bishop
dicks F7 if I sorry if I don't have
Knight F3 even if I go Bishop dicks F7
uh Rook takes F7 King
B6 like it looks bad because he has a
Pawn on F6 but it's not that terrible
like as long as the pawn is not
immediately queening E5 is quite weak
like now Knight after check is still a
threat now say Rook E7 I can go King
C5 like originally this is where I was
playing to play I'm like okay I'm not
not dead anymore right mhm but he took
on F7 and you did have that move uh
Knight to F3 and you guys got to this
position yeah Bishop takes E6 I felt was
kind of an interesting decision but I
thought he would take on E8 because
Bishop takes E8 Knight takes H7 like say
he plays some move like Bishop F7 or
Bishop G6
well by the way this is still not over I
just want to take you to this moment
after Knight to f8 and do some training
because I know you you want to do some
training after the games let's do some
training right now what's the best move
for
white I was considering Knight C3 here
actually because Knight C3 as opposed to
Knight D2 maybe okay you don't I don't
have the same Rook Knight D7 King D4
Rook d8 because may6 ever pass through
your
mind E6 uh what if
I ah you just want to play like but
Knight a C6 Bishop takes E6 Rook
E8 uh King F4 Rook takes E6 King F5
that's right so maybe like Rook wow this
is a draw
yes it's crazy yeah this is still like
like psychologically it's quite
difficult to recover after you made
after the evaluation changes like this
it's but yeah I I still had a feeling
that after Bish C4 it's not it's very
difficult to win this position I was I
was even contemplating going Rook f8
Knight takes F6 just to make a draw
because this was
not I really wasn't sure like entirely
how to win these Pawns in the most
precise way because if I wait too long
if I play like King C7 King D7 maybe
somewhere he brings Knight to D4 yeah
yeah but you uh I kind of need to force
him to you did win it you did find the
most precise uh moves and right now
you're setting up uh the scene for an
incredible matchup between yourself and
Fabiano Fabiano one point in the lead
but you yourself uh Wesley and lenier
are one point behind you have the
opportunity to potentially catch up with
the leader how are you going to approach
tomorrow's
game yeah the French has been doing my
has been doing me good let's let's see
what
happens I think that okay this this game
realistically like this okay this one
was kind of a gift Sam is Sam shankin is
one of my role models I mean his worth
ethic the way the way how he's like the
his his strength in general is just
truly
commendable like this was like I'm
pretty sure you you'll see his game
tomorrow he'll come back he'll he'll win
he'll win a a great game tomorrow like
the way how he comes back from Bad
results is another thing I I very much
admire about him well congratulations uh
amazing Victory abiani we'll see you
tomorrow thank you our congratulations
to m